hey guys what's up this is andrew from
trendsenses.com so in this video i'm
here to make a big big big big big
update on what is happening right now on
amc and gme so let's get into it
all right so as usual we're gonna start
on the daily timeframe i'm gonna go
through the press action of amc ngme uh
because a lot of you asked me instead of
doing live can you please make a normal
video so here i am i will uh once again
give you the different scenarios i will
try to tell you what can happen in this
market what
trades are possibly uh good to do uh to
maximize the profits if the squeeze
happens so let's start right now first
the price action so
um
as you know
we are moving strongly higher so that's
very good and the question we're having
is
um
how
can this move develop how high can it go
are there any potential levels where we
could see the price action coming back
in the coming days
uh to
buy more shares or maybe options so this
is what i want to discuss
um so the first thing
is that today
we have the first day okay now so let me
just remind you guys a little bit the
bigger picture so the bigger picture is
that we had a breakout above the 17.5
level okay this breakout was here
occurred with volume
okay
it occurred with volume and it happened
after small consolidation so this is a
good situation
uh to buy uh the next day
i i was live on discord i also shared i
was live on youtube sorry and i also
also shared with you uh buying order at
18.7 i think that has been executed
since then i'm a bit quiet in my discord
and i didn't uh buy more shares in my
lives just because i couldn't i'm i was
trying to get some shares on the
pullback uh and we were close but i
didn't get more shots of course i would
like to get more shots uh so i wish
so i will tell you guys here uh what
levels we can see and how this
transaction could develop in the coming
days so right now we developed
doing a one two three four five okay so
this is what we're looking for
uh in a strong move up all right we're
looking for an impulse an impulse is
always um
happening in five waves so this is what
happened here usually the third wave is
the most impulsive one and the strongest
one uh sometimes it is the fifth so here
the fifth wave was absolutely massive
um i think that right now this first
wave is complete okay so we have reached
i had 26 or 32 to
33 as a target we went 326 uh very
easily with high volume so this is a
strong victory of bulls and we got
rejected today at the 33 level roughly
where we had some resistance and the
200-day moving average uh it has created
a doji candle so a long-legged dodgy
candle which means that this is a dodgy
candle guys
so this candle is uh considered as a
reversal candle which doesn't mean that
each time you see it there's going to be
a reversal it just means that for the
first time in a move you have a balance
between bulls and bears so this balance
happened today so on the 29th of march
and i think that this could be
our second wave so the question we're
having is how long the second wave will
develop and how low can it go how low i
can answer this question using films
okay so you just measure the entire move
that you think we are correcting from so
we are connecting from this move uh we
even went to 34 but the resistance was
at 33 just some excess okay
and you can see that the 38.2
retracement level is at 25.8
so today i had an order at 26.1 i didn't
get it executed which is one once again
a very uh strong
sign
of um of bullish sentiment which which
means that bulls are ahead of the
support level so this is uh good to see
even if i miss my trade um so
right now we have reached that 38.2
retracement so this is telling me that
maybe we won't see it again because we
uh technically need to see it at least
once for this correction to be
considered a correction we've seen it
today
um
so maybe we won't see it again maybe but
the most likely scenario is that this
correction lasts at least
one quarter one third of the entire move
up then time of up started on the 15th
of march
and we are the 29th so it's like 14 it's
like two weeks right so we can expect at
least two to three days
at least of
uh consolidation
so
um
i don't think we will go lower than 26
so the most likely scenario from here is
that we consider it a little bit more
maybe tomorrow we're going to re-test
the 23-34 area uh we also might re-test
the 26 uh
support area and i think that we're
gonna have two maybe three candles so
two more maybe
um before moving higher all right this
is the preferred scenario now we also
need to monitor what kind of volume we
have for example here today the volume
was very strong
which is not very surprising because we
started very bullish and then uh bears
you know just rejected the press action
so maybe uh
we would see tomorrow still a high
volume but it should be the lowest as
possible uh if you have a low volume
during a consolidation it is healthy if
you have a very high volume during your
consolidation it shows that bears are
really you know trying to take back
control and it's not the best uh
volume dynamics that we are looking for
so
um let's see what the price action gives
us in the next day but then once again
if this happens on low volume if we
consolidate here take back some energy
because once again you can see we have
another boat rsi so another boat rsi is
not that big that much of a problem uh
you we can see here last time we had an
overbought rsi it was here guys
and look what followed all right here we
were obvious overbought in our in the
rsi and then we had a massive move up so
the so it's fine we can of course move
uh strongly higher with an overbought
rsi but
look at here it was overbought and we
took back some energy before the strong
web so here what i was looking for and i
don't think we have it fully but we have
at least um something that looks like
this we have the market that is making a
little pose okay so i don't know how
long it's gonna last uh i don't know if
you're gonna see 26 again
um but
the longer this lasts so ideally
one week this would be perfect
the more chances we have to push much
higher whenever we break out above 32 33
so this is what we are looking for we
can't control that of course um but it
would be good to have a little pose in
volume and in volatility something you
know that just gives us some uh some
time
to
rebuild this energy that we need to push
higher so let's imagine this happens
then if we have a breakout
uh above 32 33 the next resistance is 45
but it's not a strong one
the real resistance is the all-time high
at 70. so my guess is that if we have
this little pause for a couple of days
then we would be in the third wave like
i said at the beginning of the video
third waves are usually the most
impulsive ones involving the greater
volume as you can see we have a lot of
room guys uh before this volume is uh is
really as big as it can be and to be
honest it can be bigger than that i'm
very sure of this so let's see uh but
for now we are at 25 30 of what we can
do in terms of volume in terms of
volatility as well we can see much much
bigger move on amc
um so i think we will see this strong
and very uh rich in volume moves in this
third wave so
this is the and oh and as well third
waves likes to go through some major
resistance levels so that's why i think
that if we have this situation with some
concentration first then a strong move
up across 33 with a high volatility high
volume we would probably break 70. from
then
this could happen
just like you know it's very
approximative but maybe end of april all
right then we could have a false wave
pullback that could come back to the 70
area or even maybe a little bit lower we
need we would need to see how we develop
in this potential third wave
then if we come back
here in the force wave we
will we would use field protections as
usual to find our targets based on one
plus three today we can't do that the
only thing we can do is what i did live
with you guys this morning i will do it
again
we can measure uh
the the the last move we had which is
this one applied to the bottom of this
correction that was going to 13 roughly
and this gives us 100 i had 127 this
morning all right 125 something like
that
we can also notice that sometimes um
the market likes to reach the 2.61
equities 190. so let's say the uh if we
go through this 70 level it is almost
guaranteed there is nothing short of
course but almost guaranteed that then
we would go to 130. so this would be an
easy trend this is what i'm trying to do
guys i'm trying to give you easy trains
um
for now whenever we move
strongly higher like that without making
a pose there is nothing easy you know
you can try to buy pullbacks uh on a
shorter time frame this is what i was
trying to do live with you i got one
trade
at the beginning around 18.7 then we
didn't reach uh those pullback levels on
gmu we did as well but let's do amc
first so what i mean is that this second
waves and force waves is what you guys
are looking for to
create some
safe because there is always risk uh
positions to try to um
you know maximize your profit during
those big waves that we are waiting for
which will be the third wave and the
fifth wave again the first wave is just
uh you know gives gives you a glimpse of
what can happen in the third and the
fifth but it's very rare that the first
wave is the strongest and what we have
just seen is only a first wave i believe
so um of course i can tell you more than
that but i want to make it short the
purpose of this video is to gather all
the information uh in a short period of
time so this is my view i repeat guys i
think we enter the second wave that can
last between one
two three five days something like that
with a support level at 26 if 26 breaks
we have more support at 21. if 21 breaks
it's not looking good it means that
bears got the best of it i don't think
it can happen but if it happens it's not
looking good between 21 and 26 buyers
and control above 26 uh bulls are in
total control so it would be better that
we don't go below 26 to keep this
bullish momentum
then we expect a strong move uh across
the 70 uh level then a pullback close to
the 50 60 area and then a massive move
up to the uh close to the 100 into the
area and maybe even more all right let's
do the same thing with jimmy guys i'm
gonna be quick because this is roughly
the same
analysis the little difference here is
that i'm using a regular scale
that i don't use on amc because i prefer
the reactions i have uh on the
logarithmic scale and using the regular
scale on jamie you guys have probably
seen that with other youtubers you guys
have probably drawn that yourself we
have a breakout across the 200-day
moving average that was at 160 and
across the
um upper band of this triangle once
again this triangle is not perfect yes
because for triangle to be good quality
you need to have many reactions all the
way uh on the upper bend when it's a
descending triangle here we have two
maximum three reactions so that triangle
is not very um i mean visible for
everybody it's this is the reason why i
personally uh you know don't
really
base my analysis on this triangle
breakout i prefer to use the 160
breakout that was a clear resistance
level that has been pierced
live by the way very very easily by
bulls which shows how strong they are we
went through the 200-day moving average
which was not the case for the past
three four months we have the biggest
volume training since
march 21 guys one year uh so once again
this is very impulsive this is the
beginning of something this is not a
bull trap uh we had many bull traps
before so i mean you you can't say for
sure it is not a bull trap but it really
doesn't look like a bull trap and
my view is that from here guys uh same
as for amc we are likely to see a little
consolidation at some point taking place
which would be a very nice opportunity
to either get some calls once the
volatility gets cheaper i'm gonna of
course give you guys all these
strategies in
my discord for those who are there with
me
for now i prefer to wait a little bit
because it's not the time to buy those
calls because the volatility is
extremely high uh so it's better to buy
shares and sell those calls uh you know
some covered calls but right now it's
not the time anymore to try to play this
kind of strategy because we have all the
signals that it is starting so it's the
time to
find the right support levels to get uh
you know decent positions for those who
want not financial right advice at this
levels um and try to once again maximize
the profits during this uh third wave
that might come soon so once again look
at that guys we completed five waves up
on gme uh in this first impulse
uh we are in the same situation as for
amc which is not a surprise by the way
those two i was monitoring that during
my life were trading with the premium
gme was 20 ahead of amc right now they
are again at the same level so buying
amc buying gme from here is exactly the
same in terms of risk reward
um and using those ratios we can expect
jimmy to develop a little bit the same
as amc
just for those who are interested the
ratio is roughly six so gme should be
six times bigger than amc so 180 30 is a
very fair uh level for both of them i
mean uh one compared to the other uh so
here we can expect uh 160 as the second
wave pullback support which has been hit
today so same as for mc i don't know if
we're going to see it again i don't know
if this second wave pullback will last
only one day it is possible it is
unlikely though the most likely
scenarios that is that it lasts at least
two more days so until friday and that
maybe friday we have a huge run up this
would make sense to me the longer this
consolidation the better um
some of you might think that we want uh
to squeeze right now no we don't want
that if we do that
it would not be healthy there would be a
massive profit taking that would occur
uh at levels that are not high enough
probably around 250 or maybe 300
to reach those very high levels we need
to have a proper second wave pullback
with uh the rsi coming back
with low volume with new buyers coming
in with all buyers taking profits with
shorts maybe starting to cover you know
maybe not it's better they don't cover
right now so that they give us energy
they're going to be the buyers that we
would need at 500 600 it's shorts that
would cover for now i'm very convinced
they didn't start to cover i might be
wrong i don't know it's very hard to get
this information we're gonna check the
public information that we get uh every
fortnight whenever it's available it's
probably gonna be next week for now the
short interest is quite high uh still
twenty percent around uh our regular
short and the synthetic shock shot is
starting to rebuild but let me show you
that quickly guys we are still not at
the levels i'm going to show you on amc
uh quickly we are still not at the
levels we could be whenever we squeeze
so i think that during the second wave
pullback this is when this options are
really going to get built of course
right now options are hot are trading a
lot uh but
i think that a lot of investors are
waiting a little bit more uh for you
know the come to be restored before
increasing the position so bam
okay it's coming give me a sec
okay
so what i wanted to show you guys is
that we had 20 million options on the
145 strike we have
11 now okay so it's growing it was 10
years today so 1 million every day so i
think that within 10 days we would have
rebuilt totally
this uh potential synthetic shot that is
created on the upside whenever those
crash those strikes are crossed um
them
so what i wanted to show you dtc is that
2.9
uh the maximum synthetic shot is at uh
16
right now it used to be at 23. so you
can see we are roughly at 60 of uh
what we can do in terms of options so
this is another indicator that is
telling us that uh it's hard for shorts
true but it has been hotter and once
again if we want to go to those to this
very very high levels that i'm talking
about yes for more than a year and i
hope that this time is going to be the
good one i'm very confident in this
scenario uh so let's see how things
develop but if we want to reach these
targets
we would need once again every indicator
to point towards the same direction so
the short interest
the gamma
uh and the energy we have in the moves
okay so for now we need to take back a
little bit of energy we need to rebuild
the option uh open interest
and we already have quite a lot of gamma
so gamma is fine
we have the breakouts uh we have almost
everything we need the breakout on amc
though that didn't occur to me as i'm
using a logarithmic scale so some of you
will tell me yeah but on the regular
scale it's here yes but i'm using a
logarithmic scan and i think it's the
right one to use on amc uh today it gave
me a good reactions at 323 as you can
see uh this triangle upper band was
acting as resistance so i know there are
other resistances there but you know
whenever you have a scale that is giving
you confluence of indicators uh pointing
towards towards the same level uh it's
usually a level that is uh touched
during uh the day you see that so here
the 33 level was giving me this triple
information 200 moving average triangle
upper band um and natural resistance
created by the recent highs so uh to
conclude guys i'm going to conclude ngme
uh what could happen here is something
second wave full back during maybe one
one more day or maybe one more week
i don't think it can last much longer
than that because usually corrections
last half of the motive
move that happened before which was here
two weeks so one week of correction
would make sense um we could also very
well push much higher right away which
would not be healthy but the first wave
could very well be extended to 250 in
this case the first support would be 200
then 160 for now 160 is to me the level
to buy uh if we go below that until 130
we are still very bullish those are
still in control below 130 something bad
happened and we're gonna need to
reconsider everything above 130 we are
looking very good and we are then
waiting for this third wave uh strong
third wave to uh go to the 500 area
again guys like we used to back in gen
21 um
roughly you know end of april same thing
guys maybe in a few weeks i don't know
it can go very quickly it's hard to say
but once we have this third wave um very
impulsive that goes to this level we're
gonna be able once again to rebuild one
more time a bullish position around the
force wave so we're gonna have i think
two opportunities in the coming months
to create some nice positions and try to
maximize profits on the way up and the
target guys is 860.
so that's it for me i hope you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click on the sub like
and bell button so you're gonna be the
first to know when i upload anything new
and stay close to show i'll see you guys
you